[Musique]
ce soir Nicolas Duvernois
exceptionnellement avec nous un vendredi
soir et Claire Bolduc agronome
entrepreneur préfet de la MRC de
temiscaming qu'on retrouve à Villemarie
bonsoir
alors revenons sur ce débat sur
l'immigration cette semaine le
gouvernement fédéral qui a annoncé qu'il
entend accueillir jusqu'à 500 000
nouveaux résidents permanents par année
dès 2025 il y a des enjeux sociaux il y
a des enjeux démographiques il y a des
enjeux régionaux il y a des enjeux
économiques claire baudduc quels sont
vos premières réflexions face à ce type
du gouvernement Trudeau
c'est une cible très ambitieuse et
j'aimerais qu'on me dise sur quelle base
on a analysé le chiffre qu'on avance de
500 000 nouveaux résidents en 2025 et en
amont est-ce qu'on ne réfléchit à quelle
société on veut les accueillir avec
quelle sur quelle base on veut les
recevoir chez nous comment on les
accueille d'abord comme travailleur
comment on les installe chez nous comme
citoyen moi j'aimerais comprendre
comment on a fait cette analyse là de
500 nouvelles personnes qui viennent
s'installer chez nous et de quelle
manière on construit une société avec
ces gens-là c'est on lance un chiffre
c'est très politique comme chiffres mais
ne peut d'éléments sur lesquels
construire vraiment une société on en
parlait d'ailleurs mercredi pendant
quelques instants Nicolas derrière les
chiffres il y a des humains bien sûr
est-ce qu'on est capable au Canada
d'accueillir autant de nouveaux
résidents
est-ce qu'on est capable non parce qu'on
est déjà pas capable en ce moment
d'accueillir ceux qu'on accueille et ce
qu'on doit s'obliger et tout faire pour
être capable effectivement on se
rappelle que le 12 mars 2020 il y a 8
millions en quelque sorte de Québécois
là disons peut-être 3 millions parce que
les enfants et ceux qui ont besoin de
télétravailler en 10 mai sont passés de
5 jours au travail 5 jours par semaine
au bureau à tout d'un coup et bien on
réinvente notre vie et puis en fait du
télétravail alors je crois que dans un
temps exceptionnel comme on le vit en ce
moment où il y a grave besoin d'emploi
où il y a un taux de natalité
extrêmement problématique où il y a un
vieillissement de la population et où
l'économie on est selon certains déjà
récession pour repartir cette économie
il faut il faut trouver les manières les
plus rapides et les plus efficaces pour
accueillir pas le plus de monde possible
mais le plus de monde possible dans la
mesure où on peut les recevoir
et donc claire est-ce qu'on est capable
d'intégrer tout le monde pour répondre
aux impératifs économiques identifiés
par Nicolas ici
mais en fait quand on parle
d'intégration je pense qu'il faut leur
donner et ce qu'on leur propose on
accueille des travailleurs mais ce sont
des citoyens qui vont s'installer chez
nous alors c'est un cadre de vie qu'on
leur propose et ce cadre de Villa doit
permettre qu'il soit convenablement
logique qu'il trouve les garderies s'ils
ont besoin de ces services là qu'il
puisse être scolarisés ces cadres de
Villa fait aussi qu'ils doivent pouvoir
se retrouver dans les milieux de vie où
ils s'installeront dans tout le contexte
on a énormément à faire ne serait-ce que
pour nos propres populations
actuellement et comment on fait pour
bien faire avec notre monde et avec les
nouveaux résidents c'est un enjeu majeur
c'est un développement de société la
question se pose en un mot où est-ce
qu'on s'en va
exactement Nicolas les vous êtes
entrepreneur là puis on parle de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre puis on présente
l'immigration comme étant une solution
est-ce que les gens prennent les
entrepreneurs ont besoin de tous ces
gens
mais absolument on a besoin de tous ces
gens et même plus on a juste à aller peu
importe dans quel commerce quel
restaurant peu importe quel type de
business en quelque sorte au Québec et
bien dès qu'on se pointe là-bas on
réalise qu'il y a un manque criant de
main d'oeuvre après c'est clair net et
précis que déjà pour le monde qui est
ici au Québec en ce moment il y a pas
assez de place soit en garderie soit à
l'école même dans les hôpitaux et il y a
pas assez de logements sont le sait déjà
cependant on le voit à quel point on l'a
vu en 2020 à quel point quand c'est un
moment une situation d'urgence on peut
se revirer sur un dizaine comme on dit
au 25e expression bref vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire et donc là en ce moment
c'est tout aussi important il y a
urgence dans la maison il y a pas
d'employés il y a pas de futurs dans les
prochains 5 10 ans d'options là on va
commencer à faire des bébés puis tout
d'un coup ils vont avoir 20 ans à
l'intérieur de trois ans ils vont aller
travailler il y en a juste pas et les
régions et une région comme
l'habitabilité missquemin qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin des migrants clairs on a
besoin de nouveaux résidents on a besoin
de personnes qui vont faire partie de
cette main d'oeuvre là qui nous fait
défaut mais on a aussi besoin de miser
sur l'innovation on a besoin de miser
sur la recherche et développement du
milieu universitaire on a besoin de
miser sur une formation appropriée parce
que nos nouveaux arrivants s'ils sont
formés de façon très sommaire pour les
tâches auxquelles on les tâches qu'on
leur confiera ils seront incapables de
transiter vers d'autres emplois ou de
pouvoir grandir à l'intérieur des
entreprises qui les auront accueillis on
doit pouvoir économiser aussi sur la
capacité d'accueil des milieux oui
l'immigration et les nouveaux résidences
c'est une partie de la solution c'est
une c'est un ensemble ce n'est pas la
panacée c'est un ensemble de mesures et
de gestes composera qui permettront de
faire face à cette pénurie de main de
vue on a beaucoup parlé du 500 000
depuis le début le gouvernement le goût
ne veut pas revoir son seuil de 50 mille
migrants par année est-ce qu'il a raison
Nicolas
c'est sûr que au risque de me répéter je
comprends les deux côtés
de la bouche des fois là mais je
comprends les deux côtés dans un sens on
doit tout faire au Québec pour protéger
notre unicité notre distinctivité juste
un mot notre culture notre langue on est
vraiment là le village d'Astérix au fin
fond de l'Amérique du Nord tout ce que
cependant dans notre côté
protéger quelque chose c'est qu'il y a
un espoir que ça continue et si notre
société s'appauvrit puis on a plus rien
comme espoir on protège rien en quelque
sorte donc c'est complexe comme
situation ce n'est pas qu'un
chiffre en quelque sorte le lancer en
l'air là 50000 30 72000 on s'entend que
c'est des c'est des vraies personnes en
quelque sorte moi je suis un fils de
migrants mon père est arrivé en bateau
le 50 ans au Québec il y avait deux
options quand il est parti de la France
c'était soit New York soit Montréal et
il s'est dit bonjour à Montréal ça parle
français et puis et à vous êtes vous
êtes que vous êtes ici puis vous êtes à
la zone économie ce soir Nicolas
pardon comment s'assure-t-on de
préserver le poids démographique du
français de protéger le français au
Québec mais ailleurs au Canada aussi
également parce qu'il y a d'autres
communautés culturelles je pense aux
Acadiens qui parlent français au niveau
Broadwick je pense aux communautés
francophones du Manitoba le choix le
choix qu'on fera de ces immigrants qu'on
souhaite accueillir ce sera une des
solutions la francisation des gens c'est
aussi un élément mais quand on les
accueille dans une région comme et je
vais parler de Montréal quand on les
accueille à Montréal qui se retrouvent
dans leur communauté et que l'anglais
prédomine dans l'ensemble des milieux
que ce soit le milieu commercial ou de
travail c'est difficile de les franciser
alors l'immigration qu'on accueillera
devra être vraiment régionalisé on devra
faire en sorte que les gens puissent
s'installer et vivre trouver des cartes
de vie à leur mesure ailleurs que dans
le centre de Montréal c'est on est quand
même de Québec dans un maintenant c'est
pas c'est pas que c'est ça on est deux
Québec dans un maintenant il faut
vraiment faire en sorte que ce soit
mieux Nicolas
ah bah il y a beaucoup plus que de
Québec maman parce que étant montréalais
je regarde le West Island et puis le
plateau Montréal on s'entend qu'on est à
des années lumières je regarde
cette Eustache puis Charlevoix on est
allé lunettes le Québec se complexifie
en quelque sorte mais la situation reste
la même on veut protéger notre langue
protéger notre culture mais en
parallèlement il y a urgence dans la
demeure donc franchement c'est pas
évident mais il faut bouger là tu sais
moi quand j'entends là qu'on veut faire
des des études des des comités des
comités qui vont commencer à réfléchir
ok arrêtons peut-être de réfléchir
faisons quelques erreurs
dire qu'on a fait quelque chose mais au
moins avant ça parce que là on a
réfléchi assez on voit ce que ça donne
mais il y a pas seulement parfait alors
merci d'apporter votre voix dans ce
débat Nicolas Duvernois Claire Bolduc
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
bonne soirée Gérald pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI